it's so interesting because uh tonight
you really get to dress up and on
downton abbey they're not really letting
anna bates dress up all the time are
they it's very it's quite different for
you yeah it's a little different she's
uh
you know it makes sense for the
character of course but um you know
sometimes if the costume people say to
me oh you've got a new outfit because
you have to leave the house and i'm
thinking oh great i get out of a black
dress then i get a brown hat or
something yeah i know okay it'll be like
we're going to really go i think we have
a picture of you here this is about as
crazy as it gets for you that's as
glamorous as it gets yeah and and it's
what's interesting to me is that this
almost sounds like a contract i would
have your contract says you must stay
pale yes
it does i i don't have to be i just am
i'm
completely bloodless but uh you
as part of your character they've told
you it's against the rules for you to
get any color at all yeah absolutely i
mean i'm very much like you conan as
well but it's um
yeah it's uh it's in our contract
because it wouldn't make sense you know
they wouldn't have traveled at that time
so if we all went off and had a lovely
holiday in mauritius or something and
came back and we were tanned it wouldn't
make sense but um yeah i was so pale on
one particular scene that when we had to
go and redo some of the sound the
director said to me i had to put breaths
on it because i looked like i was dead
they added breath they added breath
because otherwise
i was literally not alive you know what
i can't believe is that you don't they
do you wear makeup for the character or
they they must go very minimal because
you're playing someone who wouldn't be
wearing makeup yeah yeah absolutely so
um it's a very it's just a sort of base
a foundation and that's it basically for
me and a wig and that's it so people
when you know people sort of say hi and
stuff and talk about work in the street
it's often oh my god you look so
younger so much younger and prettier and
thinner and like oh thanks yeah it's
weird you don't know you don't know how
to take that do you i think it's a
compliment yeah no i all the time people
say like oh you're better looking than
on television
and i'd be like
thanks mom
would you say you get recognized less
because they make you look so different
for downton abbey and that do you get to
sort of walk around and maybe be a bit
of a spy and talk people about do they
do they always recognize you or yeah a
little bit i'm certainly you know less
recognizable than some people which is
nice you know it gives me that bit more
freedom which is good you can sneak
around